PETE: Okay, so you're in the Rails shop, you're
all in the cloud, you're using a lot of different
Amazon services and you mentioned that you
had a lot of different sort of data components
or data services that you're using.
Tell us, for those of our audience who don't
know, tell us a little bit about the difference
between the AWS Data options.
VIDA: Right.
So we use a lot of our data we use to store
regular SQL type of storage because it's quick
to access, we can query across it, things
like that so, you know, we have a concept
of a retailer with their campaigns and the
offers that they are trying to give out to
their customers.
We use MySQL or the SQL Data store, to store
all that kind of information.
But then we also have a really large number
of user objects.
So not only do we have to deal with scaling
- we'll only have a certain number of clients
that are giving our offers, fairly small.
But the number of consumers that are redeeming
these offers are magnitudes larger.
So we have a lot more objects in that space.
And it needs to be global - global data store
so we want to have just one database of users
across the whole world rather than partitioning
out, partition out some of our enterprise
clients on the different servers and things
like that.
So for our user store, we're actually using
Simple DB to store some of the fast user data.
And then we're also using offline storage
because part of our process as a user, Facebook
Connects with us, and gives us their data
such as Likes that we can use to predict what
are the things, offers they'd be interested
in from us and we're also just trying to understand
the shopping habits of these users according
to their social data.
So that data is actually quite large.
We could use a blob store in SQL to store
it but it makes more sense to just, we don't
need it to be served up.
It's just purely for offline processing so
we actually write it out to S3 to disc.
PETE: Okay.
Can you give me a quick use case on both sides
of that fence?
Like, what's an example of the type of data
you are using real time and what's an example
of the type of data that you're interested
in more batch mode?
VIDA: In real time we maybe just want to know
how many friends you have and how many likes
you have in aggregate, so I just stores an
integer to say, how many friends and how many
likes you have.
In offline mode, a lot of our retailers are
interested in what are the top likes of our
users.
So, we have to actually go in and store individual
users and even to the granularity of what's
the most popular in the retail category versus
the music category.